all right hi everybody we're gonna start
the Tuesday evening class on end games
and I want to welcome everybody here in
the classroom and also our friends
online we're gonna be watching this and
I guess you can also put some comments
if you you know if you have some
interesting ideas so but the game I'm
gonna show you it's the game against
grandmas is the arias works we just play
this game actually recently in a
tournament here feed st. Louis Fall
Classic Tournament aid group and it was
a very interesting middle game battle
but then it shifted to an end game and
and it got pretty crazy at the end so
you will see it was at the end it was
like a study like win I was winning then
I made a mistake and it became almost a
draw but at the very end unfortunately I
had a study like a winner so we'll start
out with the opening so d4 Knight f6 c4
g6 so we don't know exactly which
opening is gonna happen yet because we
need to wait for blacks third move here
so right now we don't know the move here
so it could be you know it could be a
groom fell defense if which which happen
actually he played the d5 or it could be
Bishop g7 so it could be two of these
openings so late night c3 and now he
played d5 so right now we already know
the established opening as a groom
failed defense very tricky dynamic
opening and not so easy to gain
advantage but I had some some ideas some
preparation so I took
he took before we're following the main
line
Bishop g7 so and here I decided to play
normally I just play Knight f3 Bishop
III and Queen d2 this line here but here
I wanted to surprise him a little bit
then play something very rare that I do
I only done it only done it once one
time before and I want to ask you this
actually what is the main idea in groom
felt when block is playing this kind of
position in groom field words the main
idea he needs to do here do you know for
black because it looks like he just gave
up the center right and we know that how
important is to have the center
any ideas what's the main idea here to
play for block and this goes on with the
group of the in general yes attack the
center in specifically how you attack
the center absolutely so this is the
move that black wants to play in this
position okay c5 and attack the center
so that's why we need to try to do
something and the move I'm making it's
it's it's very interesting it's just
very direct you know it's just very
directly I'm just saying you know what
I'm not gonna let you do that so again
there are some ideas he can do but what
did I play now you you have a couple of
hints so you should be able to find a
move that I played here so what is some
of yes you may wish pay three probably
right yeah yeah correct Bishop a tree
so yeah just put the bishop there on
this diagonal and I say you know what if
you play Safari I'm gonna take it at
least for now he cannot play c5 so I
stopped the c5 temporarily so he can't
just do that so he played
let's see here let's get this slider in
here okay so he played castle now we
need to catch up on the development so
Knight f3 normal move and now he plays
b6 the idea behind b6 is he wants to
play Bishop b7 but also b6 gives him the
support to play which move that is very
important
see if I right so it's a decent move
another possibility here is 97 and
prepare the move c5 that is another
possibility 97 with idea to play c5 ok
yes no I say Knight d7 and c5 ok
okay let me let me answer the question
first
just wait one second so so ninety seven
let's say you go Bishop here c5 right
you want to take this aren't you afraid
to drop this pawn and then drop your
Lucas well here you gotta be careful you
know when your king is in the middle you
don't want to open up the position like
this because you're gonna drop with a
check okay so watch out so you play b6
and now need to make a decision here we
need to get the bishop out so we have a
couple of options here what do you think
is the best Square for the bishop to go
to the last Commission which square we
need to develop this bishop into I can
think a little bit don't-don't-don't
just raise your hand right away just
think a little bit so you can you can
see yes
Bishop d3 okay is that the most active
square in the opening when we have the
center we want to place our pieces the
most active squares right yes absolutely
Bishop e2 will be kind of passive so
Bishop c4 correct nine goes Bishop d7
putting pressure on e4
putting pressure on e4
now what to do
now he's attacking the pawn and actually
I had a clever idea during the game I
didn't think about it the later on I was
showing this game to one of my students
and he pointed out that that could have
played this cool idea so I want you to
think a little bit and see if we can
find that idea what I did was the
standard move which is okay but I kind
of like this idea a little bit better
than what I played
okay just just raise your hand that
that's go ahead Queen b3 dropping the
pawn on e4 huh I'm not even afraid of
that you have a point there
wait wait
Queen b3 he says so you're saying Queen
b3 actually very clever idea and if it
takes you want to take all you want play
Knight g5 right away take actually
doesn't work because when he take 95 he
can meet you with Bishop d5 hitting your
queen but I think you can do this idea
right away now are you hitting the
bishop and you're hitting f7 okay no I
don't know I will actually thought about
it I I seriously considered this idea I
I didn't I didn't know what to do after
he plays they'd say knight c6 I wasn't
convinced
you know because he has this month C and
if you jump in with this move here's
Queen e8 even though it's like a little
bit he's a little bit cramped but he's
got the Knight a5 coming up forking your
king and queen a king and a queen and
Bishop
yes Queen well yeah so this is an
interesting I'll try okay that's good
work for trying this this is interesting
now I didn't play 23
in the back that is an idea e5 you're
probably gonna play c5 if you know that
is an idea but what else what else we
can do here guys if he wasn't attacking
your pawn what would you do what would
you have done
yes Castle right but he's now attacking
the pawn perfect perfect that's the cool
idea I should have canceled and very
likely he's not going to take but if he
takes very neat move rook e1 attacking
the bishop and the bishop now has to
move but if the bishop moves now thank
you very much
winning the pawn and attacking the rook
look at that okay winning winning the
game basically so you may think like
whoa wait a minute he cannot play a five
because I have this you cannot go back I
take this and if he takes look at this
Queen f3 now give me the rock now give
me the rook and still give me the pawn
on e7 and the rook as well see it
absolutely he did not
all right so Queenie - I played
protecting nine goes here c5 attacking
the center so it's all the time guys
time to do what move ten already we
haven't done this move so we have to do
this here
perfect now Queen c7 developing the
Queen yes
now what you gonna do here you gotta get
your pieces in which pieces I'm talking
about which pieces I am talking about
here you can try to get in here
in the back absolutely Lucchesi one
bring the rook into the game right
protect see 396 he goes to now what do
you do
now when you bring one rook then you do
what what's the next thing you need to
do here of course what's the move
hi I assume 51 right so now we have
completed the development right now the
development is completed every piece we
have on a board is in the game now
that's already good it's a very good
sign now we've finished the development
now it goes through kc8 but the question
is now how to continue here this is the
middlegame stage now where you need to
figure out the plan here okay
what would be the right plan here to
continue this is a very typical idea and
nowadays a lot of the top players
grandmasters when they're playing they
see a position like this they try to use
this idea to start some attacking ideas
here yes okay buddy you don't want to
trade pieces your trade pieces it's
gonna be hard to attack you no sir so
you don't really want to play with
basics right now
in the back absolutely H for yes H for
now ready to play h5 and attack this
pawn chain okay ready to attack this
pawn chain with h5 it was 95 attacking
the bishop
now the bishop is under attack what to
do
so we have a choice now one would be
your idea to go [ __ ] pay six but you
already know what we're trying to do
here right we're trying to play for it
attack right when you're trying to play
for attack what do you do you keep your
pieces okay you keep your pieces that's
what you do
got it and you keep the bishop what is
the move to keep the bishop to keep the
pieces absolutely absolutely
yes now he goes is six now he goes is
six
what's the follow-up yes yeah we didn't
play h4 to stay there right we played h4
to play with h5 got it
h4 h5 attacking and pressuring now he
goes Queen c6
now it's a difficult idea we need to
find okay now it's a little bit of a
difficult idea that we need to find here
because we need to figure out this
Bishop the future of our Bishop on a
tree it's kind of blocked up and I
prefer to have this Bishop on that see
one diagonal okay so because if I bring
this bishop here I can put pressure I
have some h6 ideas so really this Bishop
needs to be improved but I can't I don't
have a good square because my rook is
occupying that square and if I lift my
rock up to see - that is a big problem
because of guys yes
see for look at that dropping that
bishop okay you trap your own Bishop
here so no good okay no good so now what
are we gonna do
that's no good
so yes
correct yeah moving the rock there and
also now getting ready to play Bishop c1
okay now to f d8
okay
Bishop c1 pack
C takes D for C takes D for Queen e8
taketake and i go squinty eight now what
are you gonna do
yes
take weaken the position a little bit
he takes it now we brought a bishop to
see one to activate it right what is the
active square for the bishop guys
what is the actor squared for the bishop
guys
yes
okay
Bishop d2 attacking the knight now he
went there
Bishop c3 g5 I probably should have
played the rook BC one here this
would've been a probably better mulatto
Bishop c4 and now he found a really good
defense here I actually taught in I'm
almost breaking through now with d5 I
did not see any good defense for him but
then he suddenly came up with a really
nice move here but really difficult move
to find because my turret is d5 very
direct attacking the knight if you go to
a5 I'm just gonna take it if you go to
e7 I'm gonna take only six with the
checks you really look a little bit
shaky here but now you have ideas but he
has this idea that makes me to back up a
little bit because I can't really attack
anymore
ninety-seven drops the e6 pawn with a
check that's a problem yeah a lot
otherwise here you controlling the d5
square
yes
uh-huh
what
no if I was a five-night xg5 dropping
everything no I fine I can take context
of everyone it's a defensive move now
attack me move your position is already
very shaky so you need to try to hold it
together here because d5 is coming
yes
huh
absolutely now b8 is a good move now now
the C file is hanging Queen c6 is coming
a lot of threats are out there okay
now
yeah now it thinks a little bit
overworked so I brought this night here
to protect okay
the bishop 97 reconsolidate should
support the reason I did this because
now my night is a nice night see for ID
at some point I can go to at some point
so if the bishops e6 Queen a6 I want to
get a little bit more in a little bit
faster to get to the end game in also
lock c7 after the play look c7 here now
a strong move you have to play that look
on c7 it's a little bit tied up okay so
can you make this move now to pin him up
here okay to pin him up
what's mu should I play but I also have
to make sure things are guarded because
the d4 pawn is weak okay so d4 pawn is
little bit weak
yes
now Eagles here
now the queen is under attack
now the queen is under attack
yes
correct now he takes takes he goes here
a five
now like I told you we put a night on d2
to be able to go where you put the night
only two to go to yes
perfect night see for now attacking the
pawn on b6 and also threatening to play
Knight to d6 okay 96 96 and I was here a
for attacking the bishop
it's
correct only move because if you go to
see to you're gonna drop tonight so he
goes Queen c6 and now he's attacking the
pawn on e4 my opponent is in time
trouble but he's playing some really
precise moves here so now I said you
know what I'm gonna go defy break the
position takes Queen c5 and now we reach
the endgame
okay let's take a look at this in him
let's pause for a second here and try to
understand what is going on here so
pawns are equal but as you can see I
have a very strong dark square Bishop my
knight only three is quite well placed
here I have the open file under control
and he's got a lot of weaknesses so his
position is like almost lost here okay
even though it's equal material but his
position is very very shaky the pawn is
weak here on a four pawn on d6 if he
takes I just take back with this now I
have this powerful square for my knight
I have Bishop g4 ideas coming up so you
can't really do anything here big
trouble so he decided to keep things a
little bit complicated so he played
Bishop here Bishop d3 attacking the pawn
on e4
now goes here
attacking the rook
goes here and now my pawn is on so I
just decide to protect okay there's D 6
D 6 was very strong here by the way
d 6 is probably also winning and rook C
713 d7 and push so this was another idea
but I see I'm not gonna give up my pawn
so he goes 96 attacking the bishop so I
wanted to take away the squares of F 4
and E 5 so I went here F 5 so this gives
me a bit crazy here he tries to open up
the position here he sees that if he
just plays normal moves he's in losing
position so he wants to make things
complicated
now I take and if he takes with the
bishop I can just simply play Knight xf
5 Bishop takes Knight take the rook if
he takes on a five point xf 5 and I'm
upper pond and Roxy 7 is coming it's
just nominating position so if he takes
with the pawn here I can just move the
bishop to h5 so there is very strong
position for me so he played g4 and
luckily we made time control now so we
have a little bit extra time to think
we've reached a move for you which was
important because I have a couple of
options here so now I want you to take
control and find the correct plan here
the point now is if I move my Bishop he
wants to take on e4 that is his idea
this
correct critics okay but I'm always a
little bit reluctant in or going into
species where he has to bishops because
sometimes just the stupid shops are very
strong and it could be a really
difficult to win sometimes when even
though you might have one or two extra
pawns but opponent has the advantage of
the two bishops okay okay but now we
reach this position here so what do we
do now
yes absolutely 95 threatening 97
Rock d8 I'm more interested in
eliminating one of his bishops than
taking more pawns right now okay the key
is to eliminate that Bishop yes young
clerk correct take the bishop okay
finally we take the bishop this is a
cool idea here look if it takes we push
here he goes here who can find a winning
move here yes 9f8
check it take the rock and if he takes
we promote into a queen or actually to
be we can promote to a night and take
again alright sir he takes I push
my girl Roxy six my idea is to try to
win the pawn on d6 this is where I'm
trying to do now I play b5
all right the key is to eliminate the b5
pawn that is the key guys so you got to
get that beep on okay how are we going
to do that
yes he takes continued
taketake king f7 be careful take
thinking f7 okay so we take this guy and
now again my idea is to get this this g2
upon his mind this is in my pocket you
know but but he replays here and here
actually I I should have taken on g2
first okay and then go to k5 and win
this it's it's easily winning but I
played this move first and Allah this
allows I I didn't think this Bishop e7
was possible but this allows this idea
because now if I take this I take this
I'm three extra pounds so he's he's
completely lost so but he went for his
last try he takes and now you need to
you have two different ways you can
continue here which one is the correct
one here you know so what's the correct
plan actually here I think both of them
are winning but what's the most precise
way to win this
yes that's what I played yeah it's
winning but it's study like winning and
other winning pawn is this guy's takes
he take you take this guy okay
he does something like this you take
this but this position is easily winning
okay the point is the reason why this is
the winning because this F pawn is much
stronger than having upon Jesus so let's
say he goes here so he put okay
he goes behind it you just push so he's
gonna have to wait a little bit and then
when you get to this you push all the
way now it looks like now you're rookies
trafficking I move it but then you're
gonna use the F pawn as your decoy to
get the King out of the way so let's say
if it sits here we just move it up he
does this you just you're just gonna
move out of the way sorry
check check check
here it goes here now I go let's go boom
this is our and whatever he does this is
your because so once you go check if he
takes or come up we have a check from g8
or f8 if he goes to h7 I go f7 f8 if he
goes here king f7 what are we gonna do
here huh yes absolutely okay Jade and if
he takes check and pick up the rock got
it
so that's the idea okay
so that was one idea I could have done
but I went for their other one rookie
five okay this is a little bit intense
here so he goes here king of seven now
you also take on the bishop so I have to
take take take take take because it's
pawn is on a four it gives them some
chances here okay so it was King this
six
and if I play afford them he can block
it and it's again not easy so I have to
do what first I have to get here my king
we're in this position guys yes yes my
goes here
King efore and it goes here okay he's
chasing the a pond so now we cannot
defend the a pound so time to do what at
the end you'll see it's gonna be really
cool win
yes
f-for okay ka3
Porsche right what else takes
do you know this corner pawns are draw
you away but the luckily here my king is
in a good spot here if my King wasn't
close to that pawn it would've been a
draw if my King was like one if King is
here to draw King here is a draw I'm
very fortunate my king is on e4 here
it's a win yes well you'll see you'll
see my friend just think study like win
that's why I say study like win actually
there are studies that I've given to
students that it ends like this and
what's funny my own game is ending like
the study very rare you have that
happening
study like win
sorry what
yeah you're gonna let him promote but
then when he promotes into a queen you
must made him if you don't mean him when
he promotes you're not gonna win it so
you have to allow him to promote yes
correct but I can start with Queen
before first year so I can get a forcing
mate but that's a winning plan first I
was gonna pick in d3 but there is a king
a to move there so I'm gonna eliminate
that by check now he goes here it's now
you're gonna get that position first you
have to force him back to be one how do
you do that queen adria he goes here now
check if he goes away you take the pawn
so he has to go here now what do you do
check and now he resigned because the
only move he has available is to go here
and when he does that what do we have
checkmate
All Right see ya it was just a hateful
how them to quaint admit you know it's
like but if that's a you cannot see one
inaccurate play by me and then it was
like almost a draw you know of course if
I have little bit more careful I take
this pawn then if he goes for the same
line is no chance because I am just I'm
just so much faster I just you know I
can just I'm just so much faster he
doesn't get that here okay so this a you
have to be careful yes i I knew that I
knew in this position when I got to this
somewhere here I bet I was just
completely lost I was like why is he
even going for this but when I got this
you played this was like wait a minute
he's got this tricky now and I'm not in
time to to do that so I I got a little
bit nervous but then I do as my King was
on the right spot
so I had this idea because I know that
study actually that you allow this okay
all right guys excellent so this was a
my game and actually it leads to a study
win at dance it's pretty cool
alright we're gonna do one study
position now okay
one study position I'm gonna give you
some time to see if we can solve this
study alright so let me set it up
it's nothing like but it could it's like
a codename a real game so here I want
you to think okay because it's not so
simple
and it takes eight moves here for white
to win this game it's the opposite color
hand down please you don't have all the
eight moves right now so so no no it's
it's not about just you just just think
first okay there's no like it's not a
competition who will do it quickly who
can do the whole thing in in your head
before you do it okay eight moves okay
one slight mistake one slight mistake
and you now winning this game okay all
it takes one slight mistake for you and
it's a draw this positions are always
drawn but here you have an idea so
you're gonna use that idea to you're
gonna use that idea okay okay let's see
now
once his king escapes it's a draw if you
don't meet once his bishop get out it's
a draw
huh all right by now we should have the
first one what is it
correct Bishop c2 king here now he wants
to get his dark screw Bishop out if you
allow that to happen you're not gonna
win this game so what are you supposed
to do yes
and now he wants to get out again and if
you let us keep Toby seven it's still
gonna be a draw so you can't let the
Bishop out they cannot let him get to B
seven
absolutely now if it escapes with this
checkmate you're not escaping anywhere
now he goes here
they did yeah I might have done this
before so what's the move here guys
we gotta fix it what do we do push now
he goes back yes
and if he goes here now what do you do
perfect he goes here
waiting move right so he goes to the
corner and once the king is in the
corner what do we do
yes yes now if he takes thank you very
much for the checkmate once he goes here
thank you very much for the checkmate
from this area all right excellent
so this opposite color you have to be
very careful guys one pawn a 2-pound
even three pawns sometimes it's just not
enough okay so here we have to use the
mating idea to win okay so otherwise
it's just not gonna work so remember
that okay so that's the ideas for you to
remember here it is very draw basically
okay so draw is a very likely result so
that's why you have to be careful when
you get this opposite color positions
but here as you can see by the forcing
sequence Bishop c2 before king c6 Bishop
ace Bishop Bishop a7 we have a mate King
a 7p v its mate
to be six wins the game alright
excellent I encourage you to study your
end games okay old you know try to you
know read some endgame book guys to
improve that area of the game it's very
very important okay so don't neglect
your end games you have to know your
basic end games how to play certain
positions opposition you know distant
opposition triangulation some of these
basic end games rock end games loosen
opposition Philidor service a lot of
information out there online as well if
you just type these names you will find
some video examples somebody will be
showing you know I have a lot of endgame
tutorials on our YouTube channel for the
Chess Club so you can look at that too
but you have to know the simple most
important endgames opposition's yes yeah
we're actually finished so thank
everybody for attending the class and
we'll see you hopefully on Thursday okay
alright
[Music]
you